live going to do some reinforcement
learning Let's
see we have some optimizing to
do and we have some fiddling to
do fiddling with this weird uh MOBA
thing let me give this stream a second
I'm going to grab one thing real quick
and then we're going to fix this sweep
thing really the only objective I have
today is to fix this sweep um we're
going to spend like hour and a half on
this be right
back
okay I don't know what's up with the
YouTube stream thing it's like indicator
on it's weird anyways
pretty cool day today
um I just noticed that while while I was
in a meeting
um so I said before puffer lib hit 700
we're at 7003 now which is awesome and
then neural MMO also this is the project
I've worked on for seven plus years
broke
500 and actually if you look at it
all of neural MO is
770 so we're actually kind of poised to
pass that with just puffer which is
crazy
okay let's get cracking on uh let's get
Kracken on this so
whoops move
this where's our
term uh t-o attach
this is pong we don't need
this
ah so something weird happened
here Max ARG is an empty
sequence okay so this is why your sweep
has not been
working uh
oan oh because it's always zero
right
yeah
[Music]
that so I think that the way it works is
with
um with carbs if that's kind of
awkward if your first few runs just
return zero reward doesn't keep going
going it just crashes
um I'm trying to think how we can get
around
that because it has to take Towers is
the
thing which I don't even know if we can
expect it to take
I can't just use reward I need some
dense
metric I mean I could use reward for now
I guess
right normed
reward
yeah I could do Norm to reward
that and uh we have a weird seg fault in
here as well don't we so we got to fix
that so that's what we'll do today we'll
finish cleaning this up these perf tests
uh and then we'll do the normed reward
thing and that's going to really be only
objective today I'm pretty tired got my
shake for the
day let's start with what the heck
happened with this egg Vault
um I believe that there was some
weirdness with
this these checks right
checks and run the profile whoops what's
happened here oh
profiler seg
faal maybe I can just figure out why it
seg faults on my own neutrals creeps
Towers players right
interesting takes a lot of steps to
actually seg
fold doesn't seg fold
immediately and I se step neutral and
then seg fault so right here step
neutrals neutral entity neutral
spawn neutral four * Camp plus new this
is
fine idx and range numb
neutrals I can make this an INT I don't
know if that
matters update
status okay this looks fine I'm going to
rebuild it just like this just in case
for some weird reason it needed to know
this is an INT at compile time that'd be
very odd but I could see it happening
okay all I did was copy paste uh the
code around a little bit
right let me see what's what's what's up
with
that uh I'll put this up over
here so
I had the neutral
AI almost at the top but not exactly at
the top
right well I can go put this at the
um I can go put this little tiny bit of
code somewhere right
PID in range yeah this can go at the top
here uh do I do tick plus equals 1 at
the top is that really what I
did hold on
inep where's tick get
incremented tick gets incremented at the
bottom before compute obs
just a little bit of weirdness with
clearing uh this Player thing
apparently entity star
player build in
place rerun
perf and we'll see where we go from
there
okay so now we have a proper timing
breakdown uh we're going to switch gears
from this for a moment since it's stable
think yeah we need Norm
reward
just because I don't even know if this
is going to be meaningful long term
we're just going to do this quickly um
so all I'm going to do is self. Norm
rewards is going to be zeros num
agents like
this and I'm going to pass this to the C
environment and
reset so we've got rewards buff rewards
now we add yet another one which which
is Norm
okay and then in
Step it's going to be instead of this
total tow is taken we can comment this
we don't need it do infos Norm
reward is going to be mean of self. Norm
Rewards
here the metric that we're going to use
for the
sweep is going to be Norm reward this
did I do Norm reward or Norm
rewards Norm
reward let's do like this ah Norm reward
is fine let's just leave
we have to add in this Norm reward to
the environment here so we're going to
do oh did we already have what's the sum
rewards no that's different we need
both
so rewards sum rewards C Norm Rewards
then below sum rewards Norm rewards
there you go and then we have where's
the sum rewards okay
rewards is going to be equal
to not like this it's going to be
reward.
death divided by self. reward death so
this is scaling by uh the magnitude of
this
weight
right so this is not perfect but what
this is going to essentially do is say
that if we increase the magnitude of the
reward let's say we double the reward
weight then you have to do twice as well
in order to match right so let's say
that you're typical
like you have an agent that has a reward
weight of 0.25 and that agent gets a
total reward of 0.5 if you double the
weight then in order to be as good as
the previous run you have to get a
reward of 1.0 so that's what we're doing
here um so let's let's see if this
works and the idea here is that the
tower reward was very good
but um it's very sparse and um carbs
need something that it can latch on to
earlier so we'll run
demo mode
train like this
slow okay very weird that it is that
slow
um we'll see in a moment I
suppose I think I have to turn off the
uh the turn off the profiling Maybe
but let's commit all this for
setup and config ocean MOA okay we're
going to add all this
okay so this is now uh pushed to the
server and where's our server right
here yeah so this is our
server
welcome currently working on getting
carb sweep integration uh we have that
already over the environment but we're
getting carbs to tune the weights of all
of the reward Wards for us as well so
basically we're just going to make carbs
do everything and I getting that to run
I'm doing a little bit of profiling on
the end and then I'm calling it an early
evening that's uh that is the plan today
and hopefully by tomorrow I will be
rested up enough to be able to do a more
full day
stream though we're going to have to
figure out what to do tomorrow um
because it's mostly going to be
dependent on experiments on this this
MOA project what else I can do H we'll
find something
Zerg we're going to do some cool stuff
here
um so yeah cuz this sweep the thing that
happened here oh this is bet that's so
funny what's up
bet we're doing cool stuff with carbs
remember the like hey what if we did the
reward waiting we tied those into carbs
yeah so I'm doing that with with um the
Moa right now which is
one so 20 M's 400 m
maybe CU that's what we're going to be
running right 400
I think we lost some performance right
yeah for some reason we're only at
570,000 this should be well over a
million so we'll have to debug that but
for now this is good enough to run some
stuff so attach
sweep carb takes half your compute no it
doesn't carbs takes nothing carbs takes
like a few seconds per
experiment and now we have Norm reward
which should be a nonzero value it
should be very small but nonzero I would
think depends on the weights that this
thing
sets uh this is training at 600,000 by
the way so that's cool to see apparently
there are good hyper pram settings for
this so we're going to leave this on the
back burn here
and see if we have any cool
sweeps this is the pong sweep from
before hasn't really done super great
yet
um I mean it will take longer because I
added these extra hyper prams that are
very sensitive it's funny that we got
this one very early on though
you'd think that it would keep finding
more from here right but it hasn't
really done
that uh what else do we have we'll just
let let that one keep
going and five hours ago yeah this is
the one that's failed so you can see
like there there a bajillion runs
that'll render up here but they uh they
all kind of just failed yeah there you
go so that's what 500 failed runs looks
like
whole how can I just delete all these
that would be
delete
500 delete
don't need those those are all
trash how did they fail they failed
because I had a zero reward function so
you need to give carb some amount of
reward for the math to work out
otherwise it's just going to fail
something that would be very easily
addressable but in the current
implementation it needs some it needs
some
reward so this is why like this has some
reward here
right and we should be able to get
something out it Norm reward
yep that's
decent we can improve from
go RL without reward well the thing is
like it was I was using the number of
towers destroyed as it's not the reward
that you train on it's the reward that
carbs uses to pick whether one run is
better than another so I was saying hey
how many Towers were destroyed but the
thing is early on it's not going to find
good enough hyper parameters to destroy
any Towers right so that was the
problem that works now though so we'll
keep an eye on
this
um trying to think what else I want to
do right now I could do a little bit
more profiling on this I think I don't
know where our perf went though
honestly because I didn't really do
anything that should make it
slow we got to be able to get more perf
than we currently have though
right so we'll look at the perf maybe
um maybe I should just map out out loud
like what I want to do with this project
next that would be good for me and
probably interesting as
well um I'm not thinking well so good
today I'm hoping I'm going to be
thinking good again
tomorrow hop in voice chat and talk to K
I just talked with Kung with for like
two hours man we had a
meeting 22 miles kicked yeah I'm pretty
burnt from that I'm actually like not
all that sore but um like my like
neurologically just burnt it's crazy
sometimes your mind is more sore from
the exercise than from than your body
it's nutty um
I still hit a 260 bench today though so
I was proud of
that so let me map out this project what
I want to do with it
um so the goal is to get this MOA to a
place where like the rest of it is going
to be fairly automated and it's going to
be like run a sweep of 300 experiments
get result make change based on that and
then then run another sweep so it's
pretty automatic so I can like move on
with this um but there are some things
that need to be done with the N I need
to integrate the skill system I need to
change up the movement I need to change
up the targeting um these things are
roughly dependent on whether the network
is learning well or not I need to
potentially do some game balance stuff
and then based on feedback from viewers
uh Twitter Etc I may add some additional
features uh I'm also going to make like
the game play kind of fun maybe add a
little bit better graphics that's kind
of the scope of what I have planned
out is running and lifting an Olympic
sport yet it's several Olympic
sports not all in one though there
actually there is not a I don't think
that there is a sport that combines like
you know low like single rep max
strength and um you know high endurance
long like over hours I don't think there
is
one okay so here we have this is this is
running
sweeps um these experiments are getting
nonzero rewards so they should continue
we'll see whether or not they discover
anything
interesting I do see that from the other
one the pong one it looks
like it looks like it's going to take a
lot of time if it is going to work
because like there just a lot of
additional hyper parameters
right it hasn't really figured out this
repeat action thing
yet and it hasn't figured out frame skip
either so I think it just takes a lot of
runs
maybe makes an argument for fixing
certain hyper parameters to speed it
up not
sure yeah fix some of the prems I could
but I don't know what to fix them too I
don't know if it's the thing is I'm
going to be more confident doing that
like this is why I want to do all this
large scale work let's say that I have
uh like five different environments
right and they varying complexities
varying tasks all these things and then
I run like 500 uh 500 experiment sweeps
on all of them right and I do well on
all the tasks and then on all of them
you know the clip coefficient is always
roughly 0.1 and it's not that sensitive
then I'll fix it right but until I have
that Concrete Hard Evidence like more so
than the whole rest of the field has put
together I don't want to do it and I'll
just let the experiments run for a
little
this what does your title mean well I'm
currently doing hyperparameter sweeps so
I'm finding the optimal settings for uh
for various different parameters of this
training
run uh the environment that I'm using
the environment that I'm training on
is basically miniature DOTA I'll show
that I have a gif on my
Twitter let me see yeah so this is like
miniature DOTA here you have creep waves
here you have Towers the graphics aren't
great yet you have abilities and whatnot
and if you look at at a high level it
kind of looks like DOTA right you're the
creep waves they fight uh it's really
fast it runs at like a million steps per
second and I am currently trying to make
this into a usable reinforcement
learning
environment this is what we're doing at
the
moment lots of details on this on my
Twitter I also recently so I I wrote
this article today or I published this
article today um the hyperparameter
tuning method we're using right now is
really really good so I made this
synthetic experiment that's unfair to
carbs and carbs still did way better
than every everything
else other ml architectures like Gans
and diffusions could be significantly
speeded up too very different
problem um the architectures there are
GPU saturated
already the problem with RL is that you
have this big stack of CPU
infrastructure that is that until now
has been really inefficient so my big
thing has been making that side very
fast so that you can saturate GPU and
there's still a way to go on that but uh
no it's a totally different game when
you're looking at like bigger models uh
that are just loading data from
disk a lot of the performance work there
is around like multi- node scaling and
whatnot uh okay though so
we have our
en
um I want to get like a
decent perf test on this
like so don't ever report back do one
envir
ironment what happens if I do
this I just want to see like where I'm
losing perf
okay so I get 420,000 steps per second
which is not that that far off of where
I need to be because this is the slow
machine the fast machine is twice as
fast as this at least so we're pretty
close I am about to profile with
standard
and turn profile is
true turn the compile settings
mobile RL is so sick learned a bit of RL
Q learning in my intro ML Class doing RL
in environments that seem this complex
as
mind-blowing yeah this is it is like
that like this is you don't see this in
research like you see this in the Big
Industry Labs but we're bringing it to
small scale research and it's going to
be really really fast and it's just a
matter of making a really good
Sim I don't know if you've been
following this project but this like
this did not exist two weeks ago this is
like a two- week old
project this is noncom this is it is
complex
bet the strategy space you're going to
be surprised the strategy space of this
game is going to be very complicated
it's not going to be as complicated as
full DOTA but it's going to blow like
most academic environments out of the
water
you got to realize that like the
standard for academic training is Atari
and procgen and stuff they're simple
arcade games this is way more
complicated than simple arcade
games it's also way faster right time it
takes like compute that it's required to
train is a very bad proxy for how
complicated your m is because like
that's just favoring Ms that are really
poorly
implemented okay so this is our profile
this is what's required in order to make
this type of stuff fast right
um I've done lit
review two of five it's out there's Grim
fun rereading DotA
dark Craft 2 Atari I if you just read
the full DOTA paper you kind of know
most of the stuff in RL just nobody
bothers to do it it's a really good
profile
what oh it's ordered by total time okay
this is fine
so compute observations is
step DOTA yes that paper read that paper
that is the best
paper there's a blog post that's the
open ai5 Result if you haven't seen it
it's like it's just the coolest
thing okay so here here is here's the
function right here so we we only
lose yeah open ai5 is that they called
their their
bot um you're only losing about a second
of perf in Python
land because yeah and then this function
here doesn't have very much
overhead so then we get from here into
step which is
here the step function
actually yeah the step function has a
that's a surprising amount of
overhead I guess this is function called
overhead this is just like the python uh
function call
Overhead and
then step Towers looks fast step players
looks
fast step
is step is
fast how the heck does it is
there 7 seconds in
here
H I guess then we get into like the
neutral Ai and the creep
AI
which what if we comment
these yeah let's like let's take the
this this scon
profile let's put this profile decorator
here let's actually we're going to put
this like everywhere except the top
level functions so we can be sure we're
profiling what we think we're profiling
we put this here we're going to put this
here I we're just put this freaking
everywhere I should actually probably
take the time to figure out how to do
this the opposite way right so I just
enabled profiling for the pun functions
I want instead of um disabling it let me
think how I do that I think if I do like
false here and then
profile nope that doesn't
work I have to do it this
way you can't do it the other way you
have to just put it on every function
it's annoying because otherwise you have
to change
it on that
decorated so I want to just profile the
top three like step player step Tower
step creeps step neutrals and everything
else is like whatever so these
skills be Prof
[Music]
fil I really just want to know the
distribution of time that is spent in
the various different
routines as well as in compute
observations those are like the top five
functions I believe
okay so that should be a whole bunch of
functional call Overhead
removed and then it's
oo that gives you a very different
picture doesn't
slow
there there not that many of them right
whoops and then this compute
observations as well which is expected
to be slow but not that
slow okay so step neutrals
has neutral AI
right and
fine if the scan Target is not
null then you get the nearest scan
Target
this what happens if I just make him
scan really really infrequently does
that crash the to the compute time I
just want to see if the compute is taken
by scan
or
not trying to link the Starcraft 2
paper there's yeah the pre-print is what
you want okay interesting that this step
creeps function is not really dependent
on the scan I was thinking that it would
be uh the scan
time but it's really not so this is not
it so then what's the
issue you exclude
friendly exclude neutrals
okay so what if we just make it pathing
right now we see if it's the the
targeting the nearest like Target
[ __ ] or if it's the pathing that's
slow I always tell people that are
trying to like do RL and really good a
sense of like the high level is just to
go read there like four papers you got
to read you read the DOTA one you read
the alpha star one you read the emergent
tool use one from open Ai and then you
read the capture the flag one from Deep
mind and that gives you Del lay of the
land I mean it shows you what's possible
with
RL and it shows you that a lot of the
time it can be very simple
so that cut like a second off of the
inference
time that cut like a second off of
so that means this has got to be kind of
slow
right near scan
targets is really cool I'd like to find
this I'd like to find the
slow oh I need to run literally okay go
run get some exercise is good for
is it really this nearest scan Target
function man I could see this being slow
right really though is
it if it's null you break
it seems like this function would be
pretty fast
fine all these Al ations are a little
obnoxious
right but again this only applies if you
know that there's
uh if you have a Target nearby
right if you don't scan anything you
shouldn't see
second which is weird because like if
you think about it how many neutrals are
there
right aren't there like as many neutrals
as there are creeps Maybe
so you have like two waves of them
active it should be about the same but
it takes like three times the amount of
compute how's the neutral AI look by
comparison it
scans if it's
null so there're just two checks here I
guess and then nothing happens
I guess it's this move towards
right what happens if I comment this
instead right do this what happens
then
whoops maybe it's the move
function it's really hard to profile
this crap because like you get the
function call Overhead of the
profiler which with so many function
calls can actually outweigh
everything I didn't mean to call train I
meant to do
this this is actually going to screw it
up come to think of it because they the
agents aren't going to
die actually it comes to my attention
that
creeps creep. pit is equal to negative
one do you actually what happens when
you kill these
to1 oh that would screw stuff up
wouldn't
it do you set the PID from
this oh you don't even set your PID here
do
you how's it work
then
wait respawn
right I think I found a big
bug in the way that I'm handling this
so I think that the way they're getting
killed they can't be
respawned though that's not what I'm
seeing which is very weird uh let's see
eval D-
render rib
maybe what happens when I do this
right okay so these guys are stuck there
because I didn't recompile that's
fine and I totally forgot to message
your guy
okay okay so wave one annihilates right
wave
two annihilates wave
three annihilates wave four
we
five
six
[Music]
10 I think it should be dead by
now
13 okay yeah there's no way that it runs
for this long way without screwing so
I'm I'm misinterpreting this
somehow okay
so you do get
creep and if its pit is negative one you
continue but then you do self. creep
if it's a tower or a creep or a neutral
you call kill on it
one so when you do spawn creep is it
setting the PID to not be negative one
somewhere oh yeah here it is
no but when you respawn the
creep you
what you're calling spawn creep or
respawn creep
creeps I see so it's because I'm calling
this inefficient spawn here that it
actually
interesting so this means that it should
actually be pruning out the uh the bad
ones right
so that already
works it's already pruning out the bad
creeps that aren't actually there so
there's no efficiency saving there
unfortunately though I can get some
efficiency saving in the respawn
function if I fix
so I'm not using the respawn functions
at the
faster oh there is no respawn neutral
that's
fine so this is
fine I'm going to call this respawn
neutral
is still doesn't answer why the creep AI
Tak so long
move towards and then we get this gives
move
to there are lots of like redeclaration
of crap aren't
there like these additional cast and
stuff these local variables
there it's funny that there's really not
that much though for me to get
at I mean the other big source is the
compute observations right
this how much how much faster does it
think this
is if I just uh recompile like that so
it says 8.1 seconds of this is
just compute
not any
faster not any
faster okay
well I almost want to say good
which portion of this would you think
would be slow right I would think it
would be this Loop right here I could be
wrong
though the reason I'm profiling it this
way instead of like breaking it out into
functions I don't want to measure
function call Overhead
8.7
6.8 2
seconds
really only 2
seconds I would think think this would
be the most expensive part this is the
loop so wait 6.8 is in
here where the heck is the uh the
compute loss then is it
7.0 from 88.6 it was
before so
8.7 two seconds of this go into the big
loop another two seconds of this go into
the or second and a half of this goes
into the
slice but then when we ran it up
here
really it's kind of weird is this thing
right here the thing that's taking
forever the
zeroing I mean it could be that this
zero is just super slow
bad I might not have to zero them if I'm
careful
see
7.6 that saves a
second that's like a substantial but
not where the heck is all the cost
coming from
here like if I do this how much how much
cost do I have left
faster Five Point what in the
hell oh I'm dumb I'm really dumb
hold
on no I'm not okay here it's
what dude how is this taking 3.9
seconds if I do this what
happens and then we're going to check on
the other fun thing while we wait for
this to
run okay
so this I had a new article today JBL is
pretty
cool shows that carbs is really really
good it's doing okay so
far um what else do we
do sweeps
anything on this one this is the pong
sweep not yet it's going to take it a
while it looks
like uh this is not particularly
promising what
huh this should not have happened this
should have been stable
generate Max is an empty
sequence it doesn't make sense to
conservative that's really
weird that was very weird
like does this do it if I just like
increase I don't know I'm going to let
this run for a
while that's freaking
weird we're going to go back to this
Dev
so it says that compute observations is
now okay it's Ultra fast
so 3.9
seconds 3 seconds 3.8 seconds is coming
from the single
slice and then the rest of it's coming
from the other portion
car what can I do about this
like observation Maps is
I can't batch this somehow can
I no I can't batch
here oh wait can I
do I have an
slice DX Dy
why do I have DX and Dy
again this is bad
right I want Y and
X have you ever looked into NE
this is
neovim I'm editing in it right
now okay so there are a few things to
optimize in this
Loop oh it looks like stock Vim
well it's got total of two
plugins it's pretty
lightweight I've got a super Maven for
code complete and SEI for some x-ray
syntax highlights that's
it I run things pretty
minimal the only other thing in the
config is the custom color scheme
native
LSP is it great for
python was a pain in the ass when I was
trying to get that to work and I just
gave up and used super
Maven Python's not strongly typed
right it's harder for LSP to do
stuff I have it set up for Python and
it's pretty good I mean if you link it I
will uh I will check it out at some
point for sure
y Okay so we've got YX we can get rid of
this crap
we no longer need RNC I
believe so we're going to start with
this we'll see what happens when I do
when I run
this mine is pretty convoluted
yeah mine is in the uh I have mine on
the
repo but like you know the neoen meme of
like yeah like congrat like you're just
editing your config
forever I don't do that I have uh a
pretty minimal setup and it works quite
nicely so I'm pretty uh I try not to be
too distracted by bells and whistles
super maven's really good
though pretty much the only fluff that I
allowed myself was uh
doing my own color scheme I have board
one
day and it's nice I like it it
substantially improves the enjoyability
of doing
yeah interesting that it seg falls after
it runs um 7.4 on compute observations
is about what it was
map wait what did I put these out of
order it should be there
right
yeah definitely was the meme just kind
of stopped
yeah I mean that's what happens
it it's got like the basic tab
expand I don't even think I use any of
this I definitely don't use any of
this and then uh yeah the color scheme
and that's all that's in
here couple Sami highlights same as the
color
scheme that's it this is just like copy
pasted from an existing color scheme and
then changed all the
colors I ran a default no plugins Vim
for like seven
years like the whole time I was using
Vim like I never messed with the plugins
just jammed
yeah it's compatible you can load the
Lua plugins from Bim script it's fine it
segv what why is it Segal oh that
actually took a bunch of time off of
this that's nice but why is it
Segal that's kind of weird isn't it that
it
returns after
Segal it returns and then
segals why is that how do we get seg
vaults is my
question did I mess up the
indexing let me un let's just undo this
for the sake of it right maybe there's
something weird
now compute observations back to being
slower I'm very confused how I'm seg
fating what if I just don't call this
does it still seg
fault it's actually funny how if you
think about it this Sim runs at way more
than million this like runs at many
millions of steps per second without the
observation computation
yeah that runs that runs really fast
doesn't it
um so it doesn't seg Vault unless
you compute
observations how the hell is this seg
Vault right
have you looked into adapting continuous
meta RL
environments regular torch ones are
pretty
bad only Jack good Jack space stuff is
like xland mini grid
yeah
um xand minig grid I could probably do
really fast in this quite
quickly what I really need to know is
like I need like research or Demand on
this right like like basically if you
told me like hey look here's an
environment that I know I could write in
I could write it millions of steps per
second and it would take me a week if I
know like yeah 100 researchers are going
to go use that in their next paper then
I will just do it I'll do it immediately
right it's just hard to know which
environments people are actually caring
about at the moment and like with
everybody just trying to do [ __ ] in
Jacks for some reason it it makes it
pretty obnoxious to like to figure that
stuff out um
cuz like if the m is already in Jack
then that's fine like nobody really
cares about the fact that I could
implement it like faster and easier in
scyon it's really like the the point of
all the stuff I do at the moment is like
I can make more M's more complex M's and
I can make them faster and better than
in Jacks but like the difference between
Jacks and everything else that's out
there is already so big right
are there other here let me put it a
different way right are there other
environments out there that are like
really good that just need to be fast
that are not already in
Jacks Jelly Bean world is this going to
be like a ligma or something when I look
it up
no this is actually a real
environment what the heck is
this what what what does the environment
look like what is
okay that's a really big
claim this a Ken Stanley this is not a
Ken
Stanley two dimensional grid World which
are filled with items
manages the infinite
[Music]
World
visualizer asynchronous
[Music]
simulation non-final
patches that need to be sampled to avoid
boundary
what this is
2020 do people use
this not
really wait where's the
this does not seem like it would be
useful for me to um to Port though if
people aren't like if this is not
something that people are super
interested in
yeah it's already in C++ is probably
already
fast sion's not going to be faster than
C++ just like by itself they have to
have done something
wrong it's crazy that they did like
something this big and that uh like I've
never seen
it this is probably why too much
configuration and stuff it looks fairly
nice is
server other clent this is actually very
well done it looks to
me nobody's used this that's
nuts I mean they're like their repo
doesn't have any gifts like any graphics
as the thing so like they released this
with like no graphics
nice well this is
why this is a stupid [ __ ] comment
here this is like a really stupid
comment but
um this is like the opinion of a lot of
Academia like no gravity no stacking no
like most of this applies to
RuneScape like RuneScape doesn't have
gravity can't really stack things I
guess you can have it dropped on the
same
tile there isn't really
occlusion I don't know what this means
but not really different size that no no
like no
no no no sure I guess there s
like like so like runescaper is more
complicated than anything that we've
seen here and is like guaranteed to be
an open-ended environment it's a
freaking MMO um this is how the research
Community treats like really good work
apparently they all want robotics yeah
and they're dumb for it because the
robotic SS are
slow so if you want to do robotics then
yeah you can have robotics M but to say
like the only M that are good or
robotics m is just
stupid like the stuff that the the high
level like the cognitive load of play of
like a complicated game is way bigger
than the cognitive load of physical
manipulation and it's not even
happens robotics is with those for
infinite compute well isn't that funny
because academics have zero
compute it's very sad to see that type
of a thing that like I don't know
you got to just ignore it I'm out of
Academia I build cool stuff
whatever that's like a really sad
reaction to a good project I didn't even
see that in 2020 as how Niche that was I
guess they didn't like promote it
properly they didn't like I usually see
most of the bit like the the big RL
environments I didn't see that one at
all and that actually looks like of all
the projects I've seen that that
actually looks pretty well
developed continual RL is just very
Niche I mean if it's a cool environment
it's a cool environment right you can
use it for
stuff I think that they would have got
it like honestly that looks like if it
were if that's something that's f and
like relatively easy to use um then the
only reason that didn't catch on is that
they didn't put any freaking Graphics
like if they' put like a big gift with a
bunch of Graphics it would have worked
speaking of which I should probably do
that for puffer
huh uh PID map Y and X I really would
like to just fix this freaking seg fault
um make like this little speed
optimization and go to bed that would be
great or grab dinner and go to bed I'm
exhausted why the hell is this egg
faulting PID
YX oh yeah I'm
Dy
DX
d d
d stupid
oh I ran the wrong function that's fine
let's run
this the second vault
continual RL is really nice though it's
just it's very poorly
defined
right is that better than a seg
fault double free or corruption
this it's supposed to be plus
one
right plus
one I don't think that solves
any rebuild
I want to just do my one optimization
that I know should do something
I'm going to go get the original
implementation this is annoying
me it's pretty mathematical it really
isn't continual RL is just
like how do we make something that
continues to learn across episode bounds
like there's a formulation of continual
RL where you literally all you do is you
just don't reset the lstm state between
episodes and there you go continual
RL and not mathematical at all it
doesn't have to be at
least uh where is
it do I have it in like a scon
[Music]
somewhere no oh here it is
range y +
Dy x +
DX I don't know why I would do Target
get entity
here this thing doesn't seg fault really
I don't believe
that I me I'll do it let me just copy
this actually I'm going to get it from
the source so it doesn't paste
weird
uh I'm going to just get the source I'm
going to make my optimization and we're
going to get
done buffer
Li uh
environment ocean
jeez okay let's grab this
simple and hope it pastes reasonably
uh what do you think the odds are this
paste
didn't change this didn't change
that Dy
DX I didn't change
anything
okay so
let's let's fix this up let's minimize
variables and [ __ ] and then
we'll we'll just be
done I have at least one good
optimization
okay perfect no seg fault so 6.9 seconds
right
not what I want to
do self. grid
RC okay and we just comment out this
essentially instead of doing this this
big copy here we're going to do it in
the loop since we have to do a loop
anyways we want to see how that
does and you forgot this is right here
this needs to be r c r c r
way no way
man I was it going to be slower
shoot slice is not as fast as I was
hoping
so I guess we leave this LIC in up
here still got one good
optimization um
yeah we can reuse XX
here still gets it wrong it's
funny so this target is
actually of significant optimization
then
anymore I still do right because the
observation map needs to get
cleared I don't need to clear
observation extras do
I I think I'm pretty safe to not clear
this I'm not positive
though all right so what's the final
perf if I do it this
way we still saved some
seconds just by realizing that we had um
this entity call wrong
I can get rid of this variable as well I
don't need
it and
this
okay how fast is
7 Seconds
still and compute
why does it say 176 million I know
that's not the
case test performance 20
oh because it's multiplied by like 400
see if we got anything out of this
little profiling session
we did add more stuff to compute OBS oh
well that's way better isn't
it yeah that's way
better okay that was actually a
substantial Improvement it looks
like but that's going to be over a
million and then if I do like what 100
M's or something
more interesting that that's
slower should be faster
this is maybe where we have to do the uh
the spawning functions and stuff we'll
optimize that tomorrow I'm tired for now
let me commit this
stuff and what happens over here did
this do anything
no
really
do I have data like why the heck this
keeps
failing I it seems reasonable I don't
know why it keeps
failing yeah
this like one two three four right
are we just not passing rewards
correctly is that what's going
wish this article could have done better
but good day
overall
um let me think what I can do
here I'm trying to think why this would
be so screwy
like there could just be something
fundamentally wrong here
we have some parameters
here these are nutty parameters but we
can try
them and
um
five let's try
this oops
how many time
steps
500k do like 150
is this thing actually communicating
reward hold on I think we might have
screwed this
up you give buff rewards here
right and then we return buff.
rewards buff.
[Music]
rewards here
and does this actually get set if I do
po self. buff.
rewards sum rewards right rewards and
sum
rewards sum rewards is going to be set
to zero
here and
then it gets set
get reward of
PID PID is correct
right if it's stunned it doesn't get
reward that's
fine death plus XP plus distance plus
Tower
yeah it's getting
reward it's weird that that actually
works but this is not getting
better that was happening
weird and then the fact that the norm
reward is low as
well where's the norm reward
lower o6
O2 now that doesn't make sense
right that does not make
sense unless the death reward is like
distance yeah that just does not make
sense
I guess cuz it's positive and negative
is
why the mean is
low yeah
so this should actually be going up then
very easily as soon as this uh this
trains a little
bit why isn't it training a little bit
that's
we have a decent number of M's like what
it's a
looked at new flax
[Music]
nnx aim to address some of the problems
you had with
Jacks uh nope not wasting my time with
it until the thing is more reasonable
I mean the whole ecosystem is freaking
cursed like I couldn't even get the
thing to install correctly like
installing like installing the next
minor bug fix like you know 0 point
whatever 42 versus 41 was breaking stuff
like I don't know what the heck is wrong
wrong with that
this is a really weird set of hyper
parameters where did I get these
from do I have like an old sweep or
something it can't be two weeks
was this one
good yeah this one looks like it was
good
right
tower what are the prams on
this okay so this is where I got the
pram from
right see so I had four update
EPO yeah yeah so it's this is where I
had it from
exactly and this is not learning anymore
that what's going on
right [ __ ] so this was actually the
right set of
is this not optimized with the current
set of
hypers I mean I messed with the way a
bunch of the rewards were communicated
right
optimized 01 is this curve going up at
all
be this should be the same set of pams
that I had before
change oh yeah so like this
this reward here is a mean over buffer
reward so this means that this has to be
correct this is actually the reward that
we're getting out of the environment
what I called it summer wordss here and
then I clear it
here I go through these
pids and I
me I must have broken something
different I don't know
what
rent
buff just put this here
uh and I will run
it last thing I'm going to do I got to
just go just I gota like I'm getting
tired uh human
backwards player.
PID
print
team okay well I found the bug I just
have to fix it and then I I can go to
bed whatever it'd be good actually I can
push another 20
minutes um just to get the sweep
running that'll just help a
zero let me see where it thinks the
ancient is
so this is actually correct I think it's
just the tower indexing is my
guess so that's all I did I broke one I
broke one small
thing I'm guessing it's the tower
indexing I'm going to double
check be easier for me to check it
here yeah I know exactly
actually but I'm going to just double
check to be sure
and then we'll see whether the carb
sweep runs or not but I should at least
be able to train
yeah okay this is it this is the ancient
right there so somehow they're
and
Towers NPC DOTA
Tower yeah so I should probably get the
indices so they're not hardcoded and it
doesn't
happen
um I bet you though it's just it should
just be the other way around right
here we'll just do
print uh cdef
entity Tower get
Tower tower.
team
r.
tier Tower
I just want to make sure I have the
ancient
right
expected I want to just make sure I have
the is
right okay
so 23 is a tier
five and 22 is team 1's tier five so
they're just backwards cool exactly what
I
expected this is 22 this is
23 just flip
them
cool have you read up on open AI Dota 2
yep it's my favorite
paper how's your reward function differ
from there it's a bit simpler it has a
few components that are taken from their
reward I'll show it to you in a second
um make sure this
compiles
so the components of the reward I have I
have a death penalty of a negative one I
have an XP penalty that's roughly scaled
to what theirs is I've got a distance
penalty that's go towards the enemy
ancient they don't have that one this is
like a debug one because it's easier
early and learning and then I've got a
reward for destroying Towers it's based
off of theirs
so okay good now this reward looks
correct cool
this I'm just going to make sure that
this Repros and then I'm going to see if
see if I can just run the sweep go to
bed good catch for the day though little
bit of perf optimization right little
bit of sweep
stuff few nice things done today not a
ton but a few nice things got done
oh and then this thing just this thing
just changed slowly because you're doing
four update Epoch which is fine it'll be
faster when it finds a better
setting if this still doesn't work I'm
going to flip
H dire level I see that they actually
leveled
this Twitter has been slow though the
last couple weeks I don't
know last week I'd said
is this not going to
work reward XP is going
good oh maybe it takes off now maybe it
just took a second
make sense oh they're taking Towers yeah
we're
good if they're taking Towers we're
good I'm going to let this run for just
a couple minutes and chill
here make sure it's good and then run
the
sweep that's good to know though that's
why the sweep didn't work before it's
because we had the distance reward
backwards from the new
update it's a very good reason for that
to be wrong
there we go reward goes back
up takes a little dip and goes back
up all right I'm happy enough with that
to just start the The
Sweep cuz if they're taking Towers then
they're doing the right thing
Tower what does normalized reward look
like
honest but then this is going to be
really
sparse we'll see what happens I'll leave
it on Norm reward for now let's see if
it
fine I'm on the wrong machine aren't
I that's
obnoxious what the heck machine was I
on this
uh I don't know what's going on but I'm
going to do I'm just going to use this
machine and run it on
it and
sweep there cool
um how the other sweeps
go 5 Seconds new MOBA sweep very good
pong
sweep 7 hours
[Music]
ago where's the pong sweep from
today this
it interesting that this is not going up
this is very
H oh okay I
see so
is it like exploring over here or
something this is the parito
nor yeah okay reasonable curves actually
that level is very fast perfect I think
we're set I think we are
set I think I just leave this uh I'm
going to call it for tonight I'll be
back tomorrow hopefully I'll have rusted
up a bit
and uh I'll think of some cool stuff to
do I'm going to go get some food and get
some rest good night